[Music]
if you've caught an uber or lyft
recently one thing you may have noticed
is that prices have gone up across
america prices are up an average of 36
since 2019 reaching a record high in
april 2022. and here's the thing those
prices may never go back to pre-pandemic
levels t after traffic numbers were
decimated by the pandemic many
ride-hailing companies were hoping that
2022 would be back to business as usual
but that hasn't been the case instead
they're facing driver shortages rising
fuel costs riders taking fewer trips and
pressure from investors all of which has
caused their stocks to go on a wild ride
so what are uber and lyft doing to try
and survive and what does this mean for
your future ride let's find out okay
first how did we get here because before
the pandemic rides were pretty cheap and
uber and lyft had managed to capture a
huge market share by using venture
capital money to subsidize rides but
what happened was when these companies
went public in 2019
investors said look there's no way you
can continue to burn that amount of
money you guys have to show us a part to
profit that's wsj's pritikirana who has
been covering uber and lyft through the
pandemic and so just before the pandemic
uber and lyft had started to say okay
we're going to cut back on giving out
these deep discounts however when the
pandemic hit riders disappeared and then
not long after so did the drivers
drivers didn't want to stay on the
platform because it was worthless just
sitting around waiting for a ride when
no one was going out throughout the
pandemic many of those drivers turned to
food delivery apps as a source of income
but now even though passengers have
started to return drivers haven't some
of them are staying put they're not
coming back because of safety concerns
you know with delivery you can still
drop the food off at their doorstep
without any sort of interaction
now fewer drivers means longer wait
times for passengers and when you couple
that with the new fees that these
companies are charging riders for rising
fuel costs it also means higher fares so
customers are becoming a little more
deliberate about how much they spend so
some people said that for shorter trips
it's just not worth taking uber and lips
now here's the kicker even though riders
are taking 35
fewer trips than they were pre-pandemic
higher ride prices means that both uber
and lyft have managed to generate more
revenue than they did pre-pandemic but
investors fear that unless these
companies act now to bring back drivers
and make it more affordable for riders
the right out market could continue to
shrink so what are uber and lyft doing
well to start with both companies are
trying to lure back cost-conscious
customers by rolling out their cheaper
transportation alternatives they're
trying to bring back those carpooled
shared rides that we had before the
pandemic so what this allows riders to
do is split fares and it makes it more
affordable lyft has also rolled out its
first ad campaign promoting the use of
its rental bikes that are cheaper than
its rides and to get around the driver
shortage uber is turning to a former
rival yellow taxis they've gone in in
new york city and they've basically
onboarded the entire taxi fleet of new
york city onto their app onboarding
yellow taxis will help solve the driver
shortage for uber but it will also
provide them with higher margins as they
won't have to spend money on bonuses to
woo drivers to the platform finally both
companies are pausing hiring and
reducing spending to cut costs so what
does all this mean for you the passenger
well for now you're going to be paying
higher fares but cheaper fares may start
to re-emerge whenever the driver
shortage normalizes however it might
take some time for prices to inch back
down but even when they inch back down
do not expect their cheap uh prices as
you were used to before the pandemic so
if you're desperate for those low
pre-pandemic prices for now you might
have to get used to pulling your ride
with a stranger
[Music]